I don't seek out pain or want to feel
pain it's more that I've learned really
sticking with something and putting your
time and your energy in on the other
side of that you're a bigger person
I do seek out those kind of experiences
where I am gonna be stripped raw and
it's not going to be comfortable not
taking any risk in your life or ever
venturing outside your backyard or out
of your comfort zone it's boring and
really limiting my dad was shot down in
the Vietnam War when I was just three
years old and so was a house full of
girls and my mom was on her own my
sister and I were home alone a lot when
we were young growing up that way taught
us to take care of ourselves to be
independent to be self-sufficient there
was never the sentiment that girls don't
do certain things are backed that way
even when I was living out of my car
with no health insurance my mom never
said well you're not making the right
choice
she really empowered us and supported
our decisions
I've been an athlete all my life
starting in high school and I've done
rock climbing running adventure racing
kayaking and most recently ultra
endurance mountain biking people ask me
why so many different sports what
motivates me the most is the opportunity
for exploration and personal growth most
people when they look at a professional
athlete they only see the wins but for
as many times as you stand on the podium
there are twice as many where you fell
down
[Music]
[Music]
as a professional athlete I have built
up a strong exterior to not show
weakness and be confident all the time
in this ride down the Ho Chi Minh Trail
to find my father's crash site I really
had to let go of all of that
[Music]
this journey became the focus of my
documentary blood road this ride was
hands down the hardest thing I've done
in my life physically but really the
physical part of the journey didn't end
up being the biggest challenge I don't
remember my dad but I really do believe
that he brought me there to teach me a
lesson that he was bothering me at this
point in my life he brought me down the
Ho Chi Minh Trail to teach me I've
learned that I can use my bike as a
vehicle for change whether it's raising
awareness and funds to clean up bombs
and Laos or simply riding and mentoring
women in my own community fear and pain
are incredible teachers whether that's
learning to mountain bike and aged 38 or
taking the biggest most intense most
important ride in my life when we really
educate ourselves the fear will
dissipate or at least get pushed further
down the road
[Music]
[Music]